(techno music)
- Hi, hey, hello?
Excuse me, is this where we
check in for the red carpet?
- Are you kidding me?
I can't talk to you right now.
- All good.
This is my first red carpet,
you done a bunch of these?
- Yeah.
- Still fun?
- Seriously?
(bright upbeat music)
(bing)
- And you ask me who
I'm fucking dating?
- I had marching orders.
- Get out of my room, go, go.
I actually liked you.
- Hey, hey, there's
the YouTube sensation.
Welcome to the big
leagues brother.
- Oh no, no, no man, please.
I feel terrible about that.
- Are you kidding me?
Dude, I haven't see a teenage
girl go nuts like that
since Elle Fanning
kicked Kevin in the balls
at that Super eight junket
which was so awesome.
- I just don't
want to be that guy
that pisses off
celebrities for clicks.
- Oh Jesus.
Hey Diane, what the fuck?
Can I check in?
Hey, how ya doing baby?
- Hello Mr. Burton.
Come with me okay.
- I found it, I found my stuff.
- [Diane] Don't
move, you don't move.
- I'll catch up with you soon.
- Well, well, well, here we are.
The glitz and
glammer of Hollywood.
All of us out, bright
shiny new people.
Where the fuck am I?
Access Hollywood, somebody else,
I don't care, I don't know,
I don't know who that is local.
Am I in Siberia here or what?
You guys know who I am right?
You've seen my cooking show
with Al Rocker, Salt and Pepper.
- Can you please check again?
It's Brian Butler, I'm
with the Downloaded.com.
- We are way over capacity.
I don't know what
you think this is,
but it's not some bar mitzvah
you roll up into okay.
- A bar mitzvah?
- So please leave my space.
- [Brian] Thank you
for your help.
- Thank you.
- Wow, she's really
talking back to
Mr. Two Million
Clicks superstar.
- Man don't alright?
I do not feel good about that
and it's three million actually.
- Oh shit, this thing's
already started.
Brittany's found her
way to the red carpet.
- [Brian] Is she in the movie?
- No, she just appears
wherever there's cameras.
Good luck.
- He didn't even
talk to anybody.
- No I'm not
actually in the movie
but I had to come out
and support my girls.
Melissa McCarthy
and Kristen Bell
who are as essential to
me as my Fierce water.
That's 50% more H, H three O.
- Thanks so much Brittany.
When we come back, the
actual stars of The Boss
when we return, nice
to see you Brittany.
We got it, we're good?
Yeah, you owe me for that one,
that was ridiculous.
- Dude, are you excited
to see Dinklage?
- Peter Dinklage is not coming,
he's shooting that wizard show.
- Shhh.
Why the fuck am I here?
- This is an actual nightmare.
Can I talk to your manager?
Do you have one?
- You did a great job
with Chloe Moretz.
- Great, thank you.
- Yeah, I'll call you back.
Wait, you did that interview?
I saw that, you're
with the Downloader.
- That's what I've
been saying, yes.
- I was actually just
watching the remix.
- Remix?
- [Chloe] Get out of
my room, go, go, go.
Get out my, get out of
my, get out of my room.
- I'm never going to be
taken seriously again.
- I'm sure I can squeeze
you in somewhere.
You've got to learn to
speak up for yourself Byron.
Come on.
- Hey what's up rookie?
- Hey, Kevin.
- How are you?
- Good man, how are you doing?
- Where are you
going in a hurry?
- I guess they found a
spot for me over here.
- Now, you're ahead of me?
- Yeah, I don't
know, look I'm sorry.
I should probably
get to my spot.
You have a good carpet okay.
- What's up?
- Between you and me, I
interviewed for Kevin's job but-
- No way, really?
- Just yesterday,
he's on his way out.
I haven't officially
announced it but,
who are they gonna give it to?
You?
Come on.
- I didn't even read for it so.
- Lyons, your
hysterical brother.
- Alright, I gotta stand
up, have a good carpet.
- Alright man,
we'll see ya later.
Oh what an asshole.
- Alright, let's do this.
Here we go in three, two, one.
- I'm here at the world
premiere of The Boss
where we are bringing
you all the action.
- Welcome to the star studded
premiere of Bossy Boss.
Why are you doing that?
- Let's get you all
the buzz, buzz, buzz.
- What's the name of the movie?
The Boss?
- Three, two, one.
(techno music)
- Buzz, buzz, oh
that's your thing.
- Yes.
- Kristen Bell.
- She's lovely.
- She is lovely, are you okay?
- She sort of
counteracts the crazy
of what Melissa's up to.
- I'm sorry, what are
we talking about here?
How much it means to me.
- You know you owe me
five grand, you know that.
When am I gonna get my money?
- Hey guys, let's-
- I will fuck you up right
here, you know that right?
In front of all
these white people.
(techno music)
- Is this movie really
about female empowerment?
Tell me about that.
- I noticed some of you
don't have your cameras out.
- Tell me who you played,
what's it like, was it fun,
was it great, are you family,
will you see them again, no.
- Was that your question?
(cheers)
- The Boss, alright guys.
- You guys is it hot in here?
The interviews
just making me hot.
- Can you just
kinda like put your-
- Thanks.
Oh Kristen Bell
everybody, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
- I'm so happy to see you.
- Thank you.
- I'm here with Kristen Bell
who look ravishing.
I always forget your last
name, it's Bell, yeah?
I always forget because
you're in like the top
three Kristens for me, like the
Jennifers I'm always confusing.
- I'm not doing
this again, I'm not.
- No, no, no, no
Kristen come back here.
Kristen it's really okay.
(laughter)
(cheery, upbeat music)
(phone rings)
You know what this sounds like?
This sounds like
you're firing me.
It's really funny (laughs).
I am fired?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
(crying)
Why?
Who do I have to fuck in
this town to keep my job?
God.
(snoring)